all right thor's next big adventure
before we talk about that i do want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by nordvpn
nordvpn's no stranger to this channel
and i do appreciate that they're a vpn
service that looks to be more than just
a vpn service they look to make your
experience navigating this digital
utopia slash trash fire minefield known
as the internet a little more
comfortable a little safer for your
entertainment pleasure and purposes not
only can you change your digital
location with one click allowing you to
view content that might not be available
in your location but with nord security
bundle you also get advanced protection
scan downloaded files for viruses
malware protection notifications special
shout out to the computers out there
known as the fallen the ones who just
didn't make it so i'm glad that there's
a service out there that looks to
protect you from that and all this is
under nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
so click the link below go to
nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year plan at a
huge discount plus one additional month
for free and now the first marvel
character to have the fourth standalone
movie
[Music]
and just so you know this is a spoiler
free review of thor 11 thunder no
spoilers in this video which means some
of my thoughts might come across as a
little vague but i'll save the
elaborations for the spoiler video i
make this weekend that's what they're
there for so rest easy thor love and
thunders directed by taika ytd and it's
a sci-fi adventure slash 80's rock
comedy it feels like an mcu parody that
takes place in the mcu first of all the
visuals i thought the visuals were great
well there are some of the action
sequences i can think of some of the
action sequences that were clean the
hits were satisfying or some of the
creative visual calls in here not to say
they happen at the same time but in the
last act there were some visual calls in
there that i thought were really
creative and reminded me of a couple of
video games to be honest natalie portman
works to a degree i didn't actually
expect her to work hey let's face it
thor's love interest in a couple of
movies getting the power of thor i mean
if i can spell out a plot line i never
really required to see it's that but
with jane foster getting the powers of
thor i was surprised at how vulnerable
she still was you can tell she's green
at this superpower thing she's asking
thor questions about how to be a
superhero i appreciated the surprising
amount of vulnerability and humanity
they brought to that character having
these powers and i was impressed with
how much this movie got you to care
about the two of them and their
relationship especially since the last
two movies i felt like they were like oh
yeah i find you attractive you find me
attractive
you want to make out
right run an adventure let's just have a
makeout which means this movie had to do
a lot of heavy lifting it shouldn't have
had to do but had to do and gorp
absolutely i thought christian balo's
gore was amazingly creepy a standout in
this movie i don't know much about gore
i just know that fans were like
he doesn't look like him and i heard
they didn't want to have gore compared
to voldemort which absolutely those
memes would have been incoming so i
guess they made him look like quan chi
from mortal kombat fewer memes that way
my fellow mortal kombat fans out there i
know you saw it too there were some
visual calls with gore whether he's
melting into the light from the shadows
first thing you see might be his eyes it
was very nasty very thing of nightmares
i thought gore was great you don't see
him that much in the movie but it might
be a case of the sparing use of gore was
what made the scenes with gore special
also when agora scene was going down
there was less comedy and i did
appreciate that it's like the movie was
like all right let's take herself
seriously and before you ask does this
have more comedy than thor ragnarok
absolutely so if that wasn't your thing
this is definitely not going to be it's
just it's almost shocking when it starts
getting funny to the degree it does and
it just doesn't stop from there on i
mean having comedy in the movie that's
fine it's not a problem at all but when
your comedy leads to conflicting tone it
even leads to the movie feeling like a
parody version of itself that's probably
not good i mean i was generally
entertained and i did laugh at some of
the things that i'm talking about i find
silly if not stupid in the sense that if
terence and philip had come down through
the bifrost and thor 11 thunder and did
a musical number i would do two things i
would chuckle and then think that's
[ __ ] stupid which is pretty much what
happened a lot in this movie i would
chuckle and then simultaneously think
that's also [ __ ] stupid here's the
thing there's actually a love triangle
storyline in this movie between thor
mjolnir and stormbreaker right i could
have gone for a joke on the matter but
it's to the point where it just got
ridiculous the characters feel like
sketch comedy parodies of themselves the
situations don't really feel as heavy as
they probably should why jokes is to the
point where thor is a dumbass even in
thor ragnarok i was like thor's kind of
like
those those short videos they did where
thor is working out he's talking about
how his muscles or brains i like the
fact that those showed us the amazing
comedic timing that chris hemsworth is
able to do but in thor ragnarok i was
like oh okay so he's like that thor now
but this is next level to where i would
make the argument they made thor a
dumbass i just don't think it does the
character justice it's a very see the
joke take the joke regardless of what it
does to the character's kind of
mentality guys in the end thor love and
thunder it was fun at times it was dumb
at times in that the description of dumb
fun is a pretty accurate one it leans
heavy on the comedy to the point where
the movie feels like an mcu parody of
thor rather than a thor adventure and to
be honest and to remain completely vague
the the movie ended in a way that i just
didn't find fulfilling so overall i'll
say this movie is fun if you're drunk
yeah now it's a party i thought the
soundtrack was pretty killer some great
rock in here this review's a little
early but eventually you might watch the
movie and when you do thor love and
thunder have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]
you